David Ayer would like to be left out of this
whole Joker mess, thank you very much.
The Suicide Squad director took to Twitter
to defend himself in the wake of a report
that Jared Leto's role as the Joker in Suicide
Squad was severely reduced because Ayer was
unhappy with his performance.
It's just the latest development in a strange
drama that has played out after the success
of Joker, the hit origin story starring Joaquin
Phoenix.
According to The Hollywood Reporter, Leto
was none too thrilled when Warner Bros. put
a solo Joker film into production that did
not star him, after Suicide Squad made nearly
$750 million dollars at the global box office.
Leto famously committed to the role; some
people, like his co-stars, might say he was
a little too committed, with the actors reportedly
being gifted rats, bullets, and dead pigs
as part of Leto's "method" approach to playing
the Joker.
But Leto's depiction of the Joker left many
DC fans unimpressed.
The fact that Leto's screen time was limited
to only about ten minutes in Suicide Squad's
final cut probably ended up benefiting the
film.
But if the quality of the actor's performance
had anything to do with that decision, the
director isn't coming clean about it.
In response to a fan who asked him on Twitter
if the report was true, Ayer simply responded,
"This is inaccurate information.
Not my words or actions."
THR's reporting has detailed how Leto was
upset over Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movie being
put into development before either of his
own Joker-centric projects - a solo movie
for his Joker, and a team-up with Margot Robbie's
Harley Quinn - had come to pass.
He reportedly fumed about the situation to
his agents, and allegedly went so far as to
ask one of his well-connected buddies - Irving
Azoff, his music manager - to put in a call
to Warner Bros. brass in an attempt to get
Phoenix's Joker killed.
"Do it.
Do it do it do it do"
Joker, of course, has gone on to make roughly
all of the money, while becoming the most
talked-about film of the fall.
Meanwhile, both films set to feature his Joker
are now apparently dead in the water.
The latest trailer for 2020's Birds of Prey
opens with Harley Quinn stating flatly that
she dumped the Joker, just as unceremoniously
as Warner Bros. appears to have done.
So, what are the chances that Leto will eventually
return to the role?
Well, nothing's official yet, and it's worth
noting that Leto still maintains a professional
relationship with Warner Bros, and is currently
shooting the crime thriller Little Things
for the studio.
That said, we're definitely thinking that
Leto's turn as the Joker will prove to be
a one-and-done.
With Joaquin Phoenix's Joker movie also being
widely described as a standalone project,
it's possible the next time we see the Joker,
it will be a whole new actor under the makeup.
But no matter who eventually gets recast as
the Joker, we know one thing: it's gotta happen
eventually.
"I think you and I are destined to do this
forever."
Assuming Jared Leto doesn't sneakily show
up in Birds of Prey somehow, it seems possible
that the next iteration of the character won't
happen until we get a sequel to Matt Reeves'
The Batman, set to hit theaters in 2021.
That movie, starring Robert Pattinson in the
lead role, seems to be packing its cast with
tons of villains from Batman's Rogues' Gallery.
But so far, we've heard nothing about a Joker
appearance.
With no other movies featuring the character
having been announced yet, it looks like the
live-action Joker might be resting for awhile.
But he's not necessarily done with comic book
movies, with his turn as Morbius, the Living
Vampire set to debut in Sony's Marvel universe
in 2020.
So as long as he can keep from mailing dead
bats to his co-stars on that movie, he should
get along just fine.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.